[موسيقى]
هنا في اوكلان بولايه كاليفورنيا استمعت
هذه المحكمه الفيدراليه في هذا المبنى
لشهادات فلسطينيين رفعوا قضيه ضد اداره
بايدن هذه القضيه مرفوعه من قبل مركز
الحقوق الدستوريه بالنيابه عن ثمانيه
فلسطينيين
ومنظمين
حقوقيتان ضد الرئيس بايدن وزير الخارجيه
بلينكن والوزير لويد اوستن بدعوه انهم
فشلوا في منع اباده جماعيه في غزه وايضا
قد يكون دعم هذه الاباده الجماعيه في غزه
بارسال السلاح
والاموال لاسرائيل كان هناك شهادات متعدده
لذين رفعوا هذه القضيه داخل المحكمه وهي
اول مره يقوم بها في ال فلسطينيون بعرض
قضيتهم بهذا الشكل داخل محكمه فيدراليه
امريكيه وامام القضاء الامريكي المحامون
الذين رفعوا القضيه يريدون من او يتمنون
ان يقوم القاضي نظرا لادراك لجديه هذه
القضيه المرفوعه وانه ابدى خلال الجلسه
فهما جادا لما لجدي تها
وانيه التحرك ان يقومها القاضي باصدار حكم
سريع وان يكون ذلك الحكم
بمنع اداره بايدن من توفير الدعم العسكري
لاسرائيل في حربها على قطاع غزه طبعا فريق
الدفاع عن
الاداره حاول في حججه ان يقول ان هذه
المحكمه ليست مختصه اساسا بالنظر في هذه
القضيه لم يجادل فيما يتعلق ب قضيه
الاباده ولكن الجدل ان هو ان هذا الامر
ليس من اختصاص محكمه فيدراليه لانه يتعلق
بشان دولي وسياسه خارجيه وان القرارات
المتعلقه بالسياسه الخارجيه تعود بشكل
اساسي
ل للسلطه التنفيذيه لذا كان هناك شهادات
متعدده من الكثير من الذين رفعوا هذه
القضيه وكان يوم ربما حافل وعاطفي وشهدت
هذه المحكمه وخارج المحكمه وقفات من
قبل مناصرين لغزه دعوا ايضا لوقف لاطلاق
النار
ول توجيه هذه التهم لبايدن بالابا كما
يقولون وتحذيرات حتى منهم
بان الانتخابات قريبه وان ما دامت هذه
الاباده واله القتل في غزه مستمره بان
الاداره ريكيه وهذه الاداره تحديدا لن
تحصل على اصواتهم بان ابو كويك الجزيره
اوكل
كاليفورنيا